في محطة القطار في ليف غرب
أوكرانيا ،
رأيت صفًا من آلاف الأشخاص
يقفون بهدوء وبهدوء في
انتظار فرصتهم لركوب
القطار للفرار من
هذا الصراع إلى بر الأمان
[موسيقى]
الضحايا الحقيقيون للحرب هم أناس
ليس لديهم ما يفعلونه  مع الصراع
والذي انقلبت حياته رأسًا على عقب بسبب
الحرب بعد أن عبروا الحدود من
وطنهم فقدوا فجأة
كل ما يتعلق بوجودهم
بينما كانوا ينظرون في أعين عدد
كبير من اللاجئين الأوكرانيين الذين
عبروا فجأة الحدود
من  من أوكرانيا إلى بولندا
ما رأيته كان
فخرًا وشجاعة وكرامة ومثير للدهشة
درجة مذهلة من
المرونة ، فالغالبية العظمى من الأشخاص الذين يغادرون
البلاد هم من النساء والأطفال
الذين انفصلوا عن
أزواجهم وآبائهم
وليس لديهم أي فكرة عن موعد
عودتهم إلى ديارهم.
امرأة مسنة بدت
في منتصف التسعينيات من
عمرها وكانت على كرسي متحرك كان
العديد من الرجال يحملونها إلى
فتحة الباب.  المطر وتخيلت كيف
كان سيكون عليها أن تكون في
هذا الوضع فجأة وأن تكون بمفردها
وتحتاج إلى الشجاعة للمضي
قدمًا
بشكل ثابت في خضم محنة
أزمة اللاجئين هو أن الناس لديهم
حاجة ماسة إلى  غالبًا ما يكون
الشيء الوحيد
الواضح في حياتهم هو فكرة الحب
والعاطفة
[الموسيقى
] لقد شاهدت هذا
الخروج المذهل للبشرية من
أوكرانيا ، حيث يرى المرء
عددًا كبيرًا من الأطفال الصغار
جدًا وقد خطر لي أن هذا
إنها لحظة لن يتذكروها تمامًا
، وفي نفس الوقت هي
لحظة لن ينسوها أبدًا